you know starting at the beginning uh my
mom died when i was seven my
my dad went to work when i was 17 never
came back he
he passed on a shipping disaster in
england where the boat capsized
hundreds of people died it was pretty
pretty horrific because it was all
covered on the news by virtue of the
event it wasn't like he was by himself
on a motorcycle or something like it was
a
nationwide event um so you know and i
an only child being orphaned at 17 that
was obviously quite pivotal in ways that
i didn't fully understand but it
nonetheless what i've recognized in
hindsight what it did give me was the
glimpse of the isolation right so you
gave the image of you up in this tower
and your concrete dome
and there's that feeling of separation
which is what most people experience
they feel disconnected from
life which is why life is all about
survival because
primarily we want to belong and if i my
experience with myself is separate then
i have to
fill in the blank right be pretty be
smart be wealthy
you know wear the right clothes blah
blah blah whatever it is
so my experience of separation was very
visceral
because it was literal in terms of like
i am by myself
it wasn't like i'm in a relationship
like a lot of people are they could even
be married but they feel
lonely or they feel isolated or they
could have a family but they feel
somehow
you know discarded by the family so they
feel separated that way but they have a
family
i didn't have any of it so at the time
it was just very painful and i didn't
really know how to process certainly my
mum when i was seven but then in
hindsight i was like wow i think
much of it was so that i could get to
the place of really having such a
profound compassion
for every human being's ego which by
design is the experience of separation
so i had the visceral experience the
literal experience
so that i really could fully relate when
people feel like
they're not loved they're not good
enough they're not you know valued
whatever it is because those
are i would assert aspects of the
isolated ego
so that was that was you know a bit of
background
but my quote quote you know awakening
was um just over 20 years ago i was
sitting in a rent control apartment in
santa monica
everything that i possessed in this 200
square foot space
and i'd gone through a breakup with a
girl who at the time
in my understanding of love was somebody
that i loved and i'm not denying the
fact that i loved her but my
version of love was very limited like
most people don't really understand what
love is like and i think they might have
got a glimpse by virtue of your
courageous sharing um but
she left me and i sort of fell apart and
couldn't sleep and lost weight and i was
calling all my you know guy friends like
how do i get it back and
for the first couple of weeks we've been
together for about a year and a half or
so maybe a little longer
and it was really the first time that
i'd felt that essence of love like you
know i had girlfriends and it was fun
and
but this is where i felt like wow this
really could be something
long term and meaning like a marriage or
whatever in family
and so when she left i really sort of
fell apart
and we spoke for the first two or three
weeks and then there was this hiatus
where i just hadn't heard from her for
about five weeks and
um my mind was ruminating i couldn't
sleep at night and i i could even
remember literally one night i woke up
my mind was so active with all these
questions trying to figure everything
out that i literally screamed
shut up to myself like how loud
so that was the first anyway cut to the
five weeks of sort of having no
you know completing communicado and
i had these these like annoying
questions like will i see her again is
she dating somewhere else
where is she will i have love like that
ever again like all of these
questions that were just like literally
quite unanswerable until
the moment where i got the answer to all
of them and it was so cathartic and it
was so profound
profound that the answer was three words
i don't know and at that moment like
well i see her again where is she
is she with someone else will i have
love like that whatever the question was
the accurate answer at that moment given
time like literally was i don't know
like that was
was the answer and when i hit when i got
that i realized wow that's the nature of
life
like i really got the fabric of the
universe in terms of the linear
progression of time through human being
is complete uncertainty we don't know
what's going to happen
yet the ego by virtue of the fact that
it's living within a container of fear
is always trying to figure it out like
because it wants to survive
so you've got this complete
contradiction now of life is uncertain
but the ego wants certainty
and therein lies suffering